people who are in their 20s still
watching this will not agree with any of
our opinions at least some boomers
anyone over 30 is a boomer hi i'm
claudia restrepo and i'm a producer on
the end of us hi i'm gabriel delorbe and
i play hector i'm ben coleman i am
playing nick bowl i'm ali vegiano and i
play leah and i'm derek de blasis and i
play tim in the end of us
my boyfriend and i broke up right before
quarantine started i just can't be
around her anymore there's this guy
trying to get with my ex-girlfriend yeah
there were parts of it where we broke
the social distancing rules do you mind
stepping back a little bit we're trying
to keep a six-foot distance thing going
on here today we're here to talk about
some wildly unpopular dating opinions
let's go
so unless it's a special occasion like
someone's birthday the check should be
split evenly no matter who asked who
else the cost of a date shouldn't always
be split evenly like if i invite you or
somebody invites me they should pay if
you ask someone out you should offer to
pay yeah i think that's like the classic
etiquette but like rules are meant to be
broken i pay most of the time i'm gonna
lie i guess that's probably an outdated
way of thinking now but what about
you're like two months into dating
somebody and i think it's right to start
to split or do one-on-one offer i like
that is it okay for someone to want to
be exclusive after only two dates not in
this day and age
especially we met on tinder like i'm
going on another date right after this
one who am i to tell someone that their
wants aren't valid if you want to be
exclusive after two dates you do you
that's fair are you going to have a hard
time out there yes there are no rules
are we living in a shakespearean play
that would be a red flag for me i think
you got to have the the conversation
like yo you seeing anybody like what are
your intentions when do you start asking
those questions right away if i just
want to have fun and i don't want
anything serious i tell them right right
then listen to be honest with you i'm
not looking for something serious i'ma
start dating like down in january
what if someone says that after two
dates to me
am i
gonna see them again probably not is it
appropriate to ask if someone wants kids
by the third date it depends on how old
this person is yeah i mean like that
conversation has come up like on a third
day like oh do you want do you want kids
well but by the third date you don't
know you're gonna marry this person but
you know you won't marry them if they
don't want to have kids if that's your
thing i feel like someone asking me on a
third date if i want to have kids is
like my fantasy you could ask in the
first day you're not being like you want
kids or not is that great
like i want kids like in january
it's a big month for you quarantining
with your ex is impossible no it's
possible we've all done it i'm single so
i didn't do it okay
but a lot of people did it and a lot of
them are still alive well i did that in
real life it is possible is it enjoyable
um no i'm good i'd rather have a dog in
my house the talking stage is the
stupidest thing i've ever heard the
talking stage i don't know what that is
it's like when you're talking to someone
it's like we're not dating we're just
talking you could go on the first two
days they're talking
to see if they're gonna if it's gonna
work yes
well that's full talking is not stupid i
think talking is necessary what if
they're obsessed with you in the
beginning like the first week kissing
you every five minutes i would like that
personally
really in the first the first week first
week hugging and squeezing that's what
our relationship is based on now saying
i love you no no no casual hookups are a
waste of time in mental capacity no but
also like maybe like it could be for you
all of it's interacting with somebody
and learning what you like and don't
like and what you'll put up with and
what do you think there's a fine line
it's a fine line what's the fine line
the fine line is you could get used to
but like always hooking up with somebody
or oh that's very good and then you're
like i'm so used to not connecting with
the person yeah no that's true it might
be a waste of mental capacity like if
you're overthinking things the more you
date the more you
you have lived life experience hooking
up with an ex does not mean you're
getting back together
yeah it does not mean you're getting
back together yeah most of the time have
you ever slept with an axe after you
broke up yeah you can hook up with an x
multiple times and it will still mean
you're not getting it and it doesn't
mean you're getting back together it
sounds like you've done it plenty of
times ben thank you buzzfeed this was
fun make sure to check out the end of us
in theaters december 3rd
[Music]